all right so we're going to come to 4.2
first everyone so that's
tab four um and your
um okay so we'll do the reports first
and then we'll come into
the commentary um deal with it that way
so the first is um everyone got their
tabs everyone open on the same tab
not the same page but same tab so it's a
joke
lead the day not really yeah sorry
i won't try again so i know i laughed
it's fine
moving on right
um so jared and joanne thank you um
for this is on a report to around the
renault request for footpath and
lighting improvements in tahui township
thank you thank you
as outlined so this report is requesting
improvements within tuahu township as
dan has just outlined
this includes a gritted path along the
eastern side of chilhiwi road from
the urapa to bramley's road
and also request the upgrading of street
lighting
through the township the cost estimate
for
the gritted path is 470 sorry 455 000
and a very rough order cost of the
street lighting upgrade would be
somewhere between
70 to 170 thousand
until some work is done looking at the
options
uh having a discussion with main power
and also carrying out a detailed design
um
the uh i guess cost estimate is still
only very high level
due to the high level of uncertainty
um funding for the past could come from
the walking and cycling budget which
council makes provision for within the
ltp
however it is recommended that this is
prioritized against other walking and
cycling
projects which have been or are being
identified through the walking and
cycling
plan there is no budget currently
allocated for street lighting upgrades
and i would just note that
recommendation c
notes that there is no funding allocated
in the long term
plan for street lighting renewals within
tuahu township should read street
lighting
upgrades we do have budget for street
light renewals
which is just the actual head itself
what we don't have budget for is
upgrades of street lighting in general
i'm happy to take any questions thank
you questions i might start those
um so how much we just remind me how
much we're allocating in the walking and
cycling budget please
it does vary a little bit from year to
year depending on where we are within
the walking
so within the planning and design phase
but averaged across it's normally
around 500 000 years so 1.5 million
across
three years okay and and yeah just sorry
to help
complete that answer in the coming year
we are taking a
pause in terms of that funding so it is
um that funding really kicks in
uh in year two of the ltp we currently
don't have
any um decision from the council
as to priorities for where that would be
spent and then and then there needs to
be time for
um design detail consultation and as
you'll be
well aware from the likes of piracy
street these kind of projects do need a
fairly long lead in time and so hence we
didn't want to put money in the first
year of the ltp
for capital expenditure when
realistically
the delivery of these programs takes
longer than that
so can specific projects
like to ohio were there outside so if it
wasn't considered as part of the
walking and cycling strategy that the
council was minded to put included
um would they if it's specific projects
like to here
can that attract but this one can it
attract 51
subsidy um yes i believe it would be a
fit
for the walking and cycling um
budget and i guess it meets the intent
of what
ncti were looking for in terms of
encouraging walk and recycling activity
within
urban areas what sort of lead-in time
would it would it need in which to which
year
would be appropriate for it to be
considered if it was to be
heated in so we haven't carried out the
design
and consultation on that
and i do think if we were treating it
like any other walking and cycling
project we would
allow a year for the design and
consultation and in the second year we
would do the physical work
so 22-23 yes yep that would be correct
and question was raised to a huey the
other night
but with the works that we're due to do
um
pursuer and other weeks that perhaps
this might be the right time
to consider putting the path in now
um would would would that be of you
start well
is there any synergies and putting the
path and now at the same time as that's
been considered
or is it if it's if all the roadsides
are being cut up
and what cost savings would that achieve
if it was considered as part of that
um yeah looking that is a really good
question and um
i'd just like to acknowledge denise
hamilton who's here
um listening today uh and she actually
has put that question to us as well um
look
with the uh in theory you can get
benefits
from um having work that's happening in
the same geographical location
tie-in and we're doing that we are
actually doing that with our
stimulus project in this area to an
extent we've
included the road
safety enhancements in the same contract
as
the water and sewer works into a kiwi um
the but the benefits are not always what
you would expect that they are
so um in some way in some ways laying a
pipe is a different kind of activity to
building a footpath they would if they
are
they do happen to be in the exactly the
right location you can get some marginal
savings in terms of reinstatement
costs but there's a couple of things
here at play that
mean i don't really think that
opportunity presents itself
one is we're quite advanced with the
water design and we want to get that out
to the market quickly to meet the
very tight stimulus time frame and
if we were to try and rush through a
footpath design and
and get that out to the map out
um we'd also we'd be in the position
where we're negotiating a variation with
the contractor
rather than actually going to the market
to get a price on it
and it would potentially jeopardize
our time frame we've got to deliver
those stimulus projects and they
we're already those projects are being
delivered at breakneck
speed um and it would really uh we we
just don't think we have the capacity to
be able to
deliver this as well at the same time as
that work and the potent the those
potential marginal savings would
probably be outweighed by all of those
other risks
assuming it attracts subsidy that the
actual cost would be around 200 our
share would be about 220.
is that right rough order yeah roughly
um around there nzta subsidies 51
percent
okay sorry i think council award who
else grabbed my attention there was a
new council dude
and stewart um thank you um that was um
my question given that we're doing um
the storm water and sewer through
hopefully this similar
area um i was wondering whether we
wait till that happens and keep in mind
that it might be a flow on after that is
completed
as as a top up and given the time
constraints
the other thing that i'd like to ask the
question of is that
um being involved in the lighting
projects for
north canterbury on that um on that
board or meeting um we haven't
got many budget much budget for lighting
in the district that's been pulled back
um in all areas i understand is that
correct
and therefore that might be an issue to
um
to bring this forward at this time
it is correct that there is no budget
for allocation to allow for this
lighting upgrade so it would require the
council to
allocate additional budget to enable it
to happen
consequently just to clarify
it's also that there's not budget to
upgrade for the likes of rangiora as
well
and kaiqua is getting some upgrade
that's going to be put forward but
but there are constraints right
throughout the district is that correct
yes that is that is correct there is
some allocation but joanne can go into
them
so there is a allocation within the town
centre
budgets for high street upgrading
lighting
i understand there's really a small
provision within
the kaiapoi town center budget or small
earmarked some budget therefore some
lighting upgrade
there but the full extent of it hasn't
also hasn't really been
i guess agreed yet through that lighting
group so there's still more work to be
able to
enable any budgets to be set there
um councilman judy
thank you um if with the community
uh two hearing community are they happy
um
perhaps knowing at some stage they will
get their footpath or do they want it
done
now or are they prepared to look perhaps
year two or three to have something done
when
the work level isn't quite so
onerous on on our team
what is the thoughts on it with
this this um has been coming up for a
number of years
in our annual hui with natura so
if i was to reflect the views i've had
expressed they would like to have seen
this done
yesterday um so that's been a very clear
message um and we have not
uh this this is the biggest step we've
taken we've actually
now got because they did request could
we at least
see how much it would cost and we're
putting that to you so this is a big
step in the direction
but um they've given a very clear signal
for a number of years they'd like to see
this
path in as soon as possible just
just to test just to signal to
colleagues i'm going to test the meeting
shortly with a a resolution sorry with a
proposed recommendation so
i'll come to you shortly so i've got um
council stuart redmond atkinson followed
by barlow is that right
kirsten yep just to clarify in your
recommendation um b when you talk about
the walking and cycling network plan um
now i was on i'm on the cycling walking
cycling reference group and it has not
progressed
as i expected and others expected it
would do in the
last year so what is the time frame for
this
plan if in fact um there is support for
the recommendation that we
we tag the proposed path and and
the path into it here with this network
plan
yep that's a really good question and
i'm pretty sure don
had done a briefing late last year i
think he may have
circulated an update to
the council um look i have to go away
and see if i can find that
but i believe that had some updated
timing
and it was indicating that it would be
later this year that he would be coming
back to council with
some further information as you're aware
mark barnes
has left council excuse me that task has
been
handed to another staff member and it is
progressing
but we still have to come back with with
a further update
i will track that down though
so if we went with this recommendation
that the whole thing
wait till this network plan we're
probably looking
at least a couple of years out if you're
looking at
getting the plan then doing design of
this path and then
implementing i mean we're we're some
years away um
i would have said i would be
anticipating that we have a network plan
which is fully developed
consulted with council and we
are consulting with the community and
hopefully have that tied up by the end
of the year
it does go into the start of of early
next financial year
we i think it will become clear where
priorities sit
and i do think there you know will be
um a focus on helping provide
facilities for areas that don't have
them so that will be an area of focus
so something like toriyami may well rate
quite highly
okay so i have councillor whitman
atkinson then barnett
oh ain't sorry williamsburg
uh thank you a question for either
joanne or jared good to see you back
from holiday jerry
um how do these proposals fit with
equity
across the district and levels of
service
elsewhere i mean do we have a policy
over the district
in terms of footpaths and semi-rural
areas or townships
and also lighting
yes we do and we do
have and we have a program of new
footpaths
and a number of our town areas in oxford
is one of
the prime examples where we have
local streets that have no footpaths
so our district plan does give us
guidance in terms
of whether there should be a path on
both sides of the road
for busy streets where you know it's
difficult for people to cross the road
um and then it is there are some streets
where we have
and it's acceptable to have a footpath
on one side of the road
i think tuahe has got
significantly busier over the years and
we're seeing a lot more
through traffic movement through
chiwahiwi and that is
in part being generated by things like
congestion on south brook road so we are
certainly seeing
an increased need for further facilities
and the likes of tahiwi and i think the
request for a gritted path which is what
has come through is
not out of line with what we would see i
guess
or expect in an area like that it does
connect through to the school
um and the church in the europa so
yeah they are important areas
um it does become a judgment call for
council
as to whether they provide those
services the street lighting itself
wouldn't meet any current standards
and again we you know
it would have met a standard at the time
it was put in but there was
quite some years ago and we do have
streets around
uh urban areas which are the same
so they um you know they were
would have been compliant at the time
they were designed but they don't meet
current
or modern standards okay
um councillor redmond
oh sorry pardon me just start pardoning
me counselor atkinson
sorry i overlapped with you that's such
a fine question
i'm just interested in the report i mean
it would appear that we're basing this
all on amenity value and use value
is there no budget in the minor um
safety budget that could contribute to
this i read the health and safety piece
here about
the benefits of of of um doing this for
walkers and
and uh and street lighting would be one
of those as well does
does this not cross into two different
budgets where it's actually minor safety
because i think you find
so here we over the years has talked
about particularly the scorpios
about it being safety issues so i'm just
wondering why we have nothing now the
minor safety budget in here and this is
all new
new budget because there must be stuff
there that could go to this a percentage
that's a really good question
our miner safety budget across all
categories
is five hundred thousand dollars so that
includes minor lighting upgrades
intersection
improvements um a small walking and
cycling budget of around
fifty thousand dollars um and these are
i think roadside has removal which is a
hundred thousand dollars a year
there's a number of different sub
buckets that fit within the miner safety
bucket itself
so the minor lighting upgrades is thirty
thousand dollars a year
it's a very small um budget that is
available
we could look to slowly over time
use that thirty thousand a year to
upgrade lighting in into a huey
probably just uh um two
things that i would flag with that is
the street lights are currently on the
power pulse
um and of main power allow us
to put additional street lights onto
other power poles that may
be sufficient but that requires them to
allow us to attach to the infrastructure
which they seem to be
less and less or more and more reluctant
to do
and if we can't do that it does mean
installing our street lighting cables in
the ground
and putting in street light poles so
that's why there's a range in price
um you know budget that i've got for
this street lighting do you understand
some questions there is an element of
this
that is a health and safety and and a
safety issue
and that budget i'm not talking about
funding that through the
through the uh through that safety
budget i'm talking about there must be a
percentage
where you know pick your figure of 30
overall this project must have a
percentage of safety issues that you
could take from the minor
safety budget to put towards this so
at nzta how they set up their funding
criteria
is they have a category which is called
low cost low risk where all of our
safety projects come from
and minor improvement the miner safety
bucket is just one of those that's set
within that
so these would need to come from those
that that area um so
yes it would have nzta funding but it
wouldn't necessarily have to sit
within the miner safety bucket which is
a very small portion of the overall
low cost low risk program if that makes
sense
so yes it would get funding yes it would
get funding under a safety banner
but it doesn't have to sit in miner
safety
okay
firstly question a process these two
issues appear to be quite separate
even though they're connected is it
possible to take them separately
when we actually go to try and move sure
yes happy for them to be considered well
considered separately
yes yeah thank you that's wonderful um
the second question i've got
is um when we did the wooden beach
pathway the community did the
fundraising pdu did the design so there
was council support but community
fundraising
is it possible that something like that
could happen to speed up
uh the actual provision of this if there
was some community input
into the gritted path to get it going
i suspect that's something we would need
to
take back to rooney and see whether
there was interest in doing that sure
and you've mentioned a figure the main
mentioned effect of 220k with subsidy
is it not correct that this would not
meet the meet the criteria under our
current policy
for subsidy within zta
i apologize sorry which one the path
sorry
would not meet the criteria for subsidy
at the moment under our current quality
um
no i believe it would uh fit within the
um the walking and cycling
but not the footpaths policy not the not
the standard footpath provision policies
for it
so nzta generally don't
fund any new footpaths so
the funding we have the hundred thousand
a year for new footpaths
is purely funded by council
and that is used for the new footpaths
that have already been identified around
the district so the figure that you've
mentioned here is 455k
approximately to actually do the
footpath is that the correct fit
yes and i would and my assumption is we
would be able to do that
under the walking and cycling budget
right which
is nzta subsidised and fits within that
low cost low risk category and i'm sorry
i know it's very cool you've got that
now it's a bit confusing
yeah no that's cool um and
would there be a possibility that the
community could get a local contractor
to do that
cheaper if they were doing it on a
community basis as was done with the
wooden beach pathway
yeah so i think with the woody m beach
pathway i jogged my memory this was back
into ken stevenson's time but i think
there was a
small payment to the contractor
and then the rest was council design and
supervision cost
so there was an obvious arrangement
between between the two which did
mean that it was delivered much cheaper
great yeah
and now on the second point of the
lighting which is like a secret report
for me
um you've put in 3.8 that this does not
meet the current lighting standards
which you've noted
how many areas in the district are you
aware do not meet the current lighting
standards and need upgrading
oh look i would say we've got lots lots
i mean we had the issue in oxford
where we changed to the leds and that
made that much more obvious and
i think from memory it was
around two hundred thousand hundred and
fifty to two hundred thousand to upgrade
oxford
to meet current standards and that was
just a
selection of streets and knocks but we
would have the same situation here in
renewal where we have streets that were
designed and street lighting installed
years ago and they wouldn't meet
the current standards either looking at
the situation the main street of a
village
would there be other main streets of
small settlements in the
in the district that would have similar
lighting standards
um yes we haven't to my knowledge done
any lighting upgrade if you look at the
beaches
or ashley we haven't
upgraded lighting in any of those
settlements
and if the council on 4.2
you've noted that you'd like to do more
investigation
to get a proper idea of the cost
considering the main
power issue as well um
but if the council was of the mind to
progress the lighting
um due to the activity increase
we could put budget into this this
year's
plan and you could come back if
additional was required
yes sir that's something for council to
consider
we can go away and i guess do some
investigation
have a discussion with main power and
potentially do
a lighting design for a relatively small
cost
which would then give more certainty so
i guess that statement was
just around we can go away and do some
of that work
first if that's the preference before
the budget set
but that's the council if we did the
budget now would that speed up the
process of actually getting the lights
done
um i don't think so because we can
potentially
do their lighting design from within
some of our existing maintenance budgets
anyway thank you
guys clarify one of the answers to
council balance questions around the
footpaths
because my question before was if it was
a standalone project
um could specific projects like to hear
we attract
the 51 subsidy my recollection of your
answer was that yes
so what you've been answered before was
if it's out if it's outside the walking
and cycling then it wouldn't attract
subset can you just clarify that
for me please sorry my assumption was
that it would sit
it would still sit within the walking
and cycling
category because that's what it is it's
a path so it has to sit within their
area
within the low cost low risk right
so if we decided to add extra budget
today to make this
project happen outside well
outside the 500 000 allocation
would would that not attract subsidy if
it was over and above
so we would have to um
[Music]
we would have to go away and talk to
nzta
and include that within our bid so it
would still sit
within okay yes sorry this is not
understand
the process gets very confusing but it
would still
within our nzta bid it was still sit
within the low-cost low-risk
walking and cycling area thank you so
they categorise all the
projects into different buckets and we
we have to fit into one of those
yeah thanks joanne um councillor
williams
um two questions with with the um
51 um government um subsidy on it
is that unlimited or would that if we
use the
um a couple hundred thousand out of that
would that affect some other
type of footpath or what have you in the
area
so when we put our bid into nzta
we have to put in the projects that
we would like that we want to put
forward that we want to do as a district
and then nzta approve
a program of work and it may be some or
all of what we apply for
um what they then approve to us for
funding is the cap
so we can't go beyond that unless we
apply for
and they approve it does that make sense
no it was a yes or no so it was a yes or
no
so can we just add an additional project
no we can't
no okay sorry and the other question is
is there uh another government subsidy
looking at coming up for
led lighting replacements
no it won't be okay
any further questions award sorry
just to clarify not at the 85 percent
that it was it will remain at the 51
but not the 85.
i'm just wondering whether you could do
some more um
homework on it seems to me and go to
main power to see if
the cost will be if they would look at
increasing the lighting on their present
poles
given what it's for um if not
at the same time if we well we've got
well
if we've got the um the sewer and
everything up then
it would make would it not make sense to
put the line through for
a very good question you're getting
you're getting to that question
but but you know would it not make sense
that when we've got the
the sewer and the ground up that we put
the the
um the um infrastructure in for lighting
at the same time it cost for that if
main power don't come to the party
so there's two things with that we don't
want to be putting infrastructure into
the ground which we don't require
and we need to have that discussion with
the main power first and potentially get
that lighting design
done so we otherwise we would end up in
the situation where we are
funding something that we don't use
so we wouldn't we wouldn't do that until
we had the lighting design confirmed and
i think the risk with this one
is getting main power approvals can take
quite an amount of time
subsequent then it's going to be quite a
while at the timeline of doing this
we're a year out from completing that
are we
no we're um just about to award the
tender for that
piece of construction so it's so we've
lost the opportunity really and we did
talk to all of the utility providers
earlier
um so and i suppose i'll go back to the
answer i gave to the footpath that
the benefits don't always actually um
end up being as much as you'd expected
they would be
um council redmond you had a further
question yes thank you mr mayor
um i just wondered if we could ask jeff
if this work was
brought forward based on the costings
that we know of
with or without the nzta subsidy
what effect would that have on
rate increases
don't want to answer for jeff it depends
how you want to
deal with it because some of our rates
are smoothed
so the net additional funding
requirement
if it was eligible for subsidies and you
know
200 250 000 of a capital project
which would typically be debt funded
it it has an impact but it would be
marginal in the roundings of rates over
the period of the
term it would be smoothed you would
you would hardly notice you know the
rate impact would not be that great
per say it will be double it if there
wasn't
zta funding right
one final question and then i'm going to
move to recommend a recommendation
sorry very confused 1.6 clearly says
it's 455
000 if we get subsidy so it's
oh can you just clarify that
rather than 250. okay so uh 1.6
is the estimated cost of of constructing
the path is 455 000
that's the total cost okay including
nzta subsidy
and council share
okay is that all clear all right well
i'm going to test the
meeting with the recommendation
emotion sorry so um that a we receive
the report b includes budget of 450 000
for a gritted path in the tuahebe
township
in 2223 or 2022
23 c requests
a report for street light
upgrade within to a huge township in
time for consideration
in next year's annual plan i wouldn't
the current d wording would come out and
the the e would become d
do i have a second seconded by
councillor atkinson
i think um this matters well over due
we've
i look as many uh huis as i've been to
over the years it has come up every year
uh we've worked really
well in partnership with our roon under
in terms of identifying key projects and
this is one of them
that is regularly raised and is raised
with me as a priority at all the
meetings
we go to um and in our annual huis but
also
in relation more recently was around
speed limits in the village as well and
during that consultation
there were significant concerns raised
by
the school and the preschool around the
connections
that exists on that side of the road
there was a question before around
would and a really good question around
whether the community would partner and
and local karma tour
as well well i got a very clear message
that they did that last time
because when the current footpath went
in that was actually put in
um uh and constructed with the efforts
of
um our local runaway in partnership so
that's how that was constructed
got the message that um there probably
isn't the same ability to do that now
because of
age and other other matters which and i
don't think that
in this day and age we should
necessarily expect our community to do
that unless they're willing
and there's really good partnerships but
i've got that research quite clearly
there's work to be done a reason i'm
saying 22 23
in terms of design work there's work to
be done with
um pastor europa and to work with mariah
trustees to
work out the appropriate alignments
because there will be
if this goes in there will be some
change in terms of
car parking around there and we just
need to make sure that we're
clear about that um i hope this project
would attract subsidy and i think
this is one given the speed limit that
we could put a very good case to nzta
for we'll see how that goes we some
years ago
there is precedent in doing this we
decided that
in oxford um there was a range of
deficiencies
in the township and we put money in the
budget to address those
footpath deficiencies because they were
just never going to get up there in
terms of walking and cycling amongst all
the other
priorities that we were in the district
i think this
is one that is the right time that we
consider this matter in terms of the
um street lighting i'd like further work
done on that
as i've requested recommended in this
motion that it comes back in
consideration for
next year's annual plan and we can
consider that matter now
but i think the footpath doesn't matter
it's well documented
it's been well lobbied for and i think
it's time that we
um consider it and um i i would hope
that colleagues would agree that it
should be included
counselor atkinson thank you mr mia i
i'd like to echo uh the mia's uh uh
mia's comments but i'd also
like to add that there are to my
knowledge
no other villages of a
um short length if you like of a main
street we'll call it that for what a
better terms
that house a school in europa
and mirai it's not just the residents
who live in this area
that is what is attracted to that area
for hui for uh for um
uh unfortunately tangy
or fortunately whichever way you see
that um and also
uh things like the health day that they
have at mirai all of those things this
is a pretty
highly used area and
does sit a little differently to some of
the other areas in which we have
we do have some rural areas that lack
footpath and lighting
but again they don't have the school
right next door or the school
school hall uh sorry the hall is further
down the road
and urapa are not particularly in those
settlements so this
this by its very nature in my view is a
little different
to um to other areas in which um
which sit in our district someone may be
able to pull one out of the hat that's
that's the same but i i certainly can't
think of one that uh
doesn't have adequate um
lighting and footpaths around it
with those same with the same amenity
value that's in there there's also a
sports ground beside the school
which is used in the weekends and so on
and in evenings
certainly dutch rugby um you know
getting on to the evening so i
i think that this investment is a little
overdue
it has been asked for for a long time as
long as i can remember and
believe me with my walking stick i've
been around this table for a wee while
and i
along with the mirror don't remember um
a hui that i've been to with us hasn't
been asked for and we've uh
we've given on the odd occasion some
pretty hairy fury answers to uh
yes we'll look at that and i think the
rubber needs to hit the road at some
point
timing right may not be financially
right for us but
timing's right in the fact that we're
starting to run out of roads so to speak
and we
we're running out of excuses and i think
that we need to
to look at this seriously and get it
done and certainly with the rat running
that's happening through
through to ahiwe at the moment that's
another thing that's
really picked up through there for the
speakers
because guess brian jewish speaks
with regard to the 455 that was that
purely our money or
were you including well
from my point of view i'm hoping it
would attract subsidy
that would rely on our bid that's
how i took joanne's comments
thank you just very briefly speaking uh
to it and after a presentation we had
late last
year and to take some time to spend
in my professional capacity and two here
we just of interest in the 80k
area of the five tickets i issued four
went to locals
sitting in the 50k area just to the
south of the school the biggest issue
was parents dropping children off at the
preschool or
the school and then accelerating hard
heading
towards christchurch in excess of the
50k area i do support the inclusion of
of this and i do like the time gap that
you've given it because i do want it to
marry up with don young's
uh don yang's work and obviously there's
a conversation that he had with the main
power regarding the rights
thank you uh councillor williams
followed by council blackhead
sorry in duty thank you
mine was a wee bit of a same question as
councillor bryan's about the subsidy the
way the motion's put
it's um without the subsidy
would you be um quite
happy to amend the motion to include the
subsidy in that um
scenario and um well um
i'm i'm happy with it as it's presently
worded
because that'll be a further
consideration but i wasn't planning to
make it subject to
on there and um i'm
replying to council actors and we've got
bus exchange and river road now with no
footpath access to it it's got the um
bowling club the pro k club we've got
dog park
on that side of the road there's no
footpath whatsoever going to those
amenities a
similar type of scenario we've got a
footpath on one side
not the other side
thank you uh councillor blackie if
because robbie covered most of what i
was going to say
i'll support this it's overdue
it's timely there's no way we can get it
done faster than 22
23 because we have to tie it in with the
cycle and walkway scheme as it's been
discussed
so i'm happy to support it council duty
thank you yes i'd be happy to support
this
that time out there for 22 23 year
um it's it's uh having walked that
area with mr cleary a couple three about
three years ago
it really is most important too and also
um talking about uh councillor
kirsten uh spoke about you know building
a
helping to build up themselves well i've
actually built a footpath because we
had no other choice but to build it and
men are like i wouldn't do it again
thanks councilwood council
just a question as the so the figure is
455 in the motion is that correct or
220.
oh well i put 450. 450. sorry i just
wanted to clarify
um is this in addition to the current
walking and cycling budget that's
already there so that other areas don't
miss out well that's my
that's your intention it was my
intention but as i said before i was
hopeful that
we would attract subsidies but i'll
address that and write a reply
no i mean the current budget that's
already there it's in addition
to it thank you on that basis i'm happy
to support it
my main concern was that we don't have a
very big walking and cycling budget
and um to not have actually looked at
the whole district and considered the
budget we've already allocated
and for all the other areas such as
everything from river road to waikuku
beach has got shocking footpaths and we
have a huge influx of summer visitors
and two other areas in our district who
may want to be included in that strategy
of getting people from a to b including
the important link between kaiapoi wood
end which is really really important for
walking and cycling um i i was a woody
dashie councillor and i've heard this
um come to just about every hui that
we've been to i was actually quite
astonished
that an area with this high level of
activity with a school a preschool a
sports ground
an urupa and a mirai the most important
cultural destination in our district
didn't have footpaths on both sides of
the main road
but i do understand we've been under
huge budget constraints with the
earthquake
and with other things happening and now
it's time to start putting some of those
things right
so i'm actually in favor of putting this
into the 22-23 year
getting it right and starting to move
forward it's and i'm hoping that joanne
will put a very good case to nzta
um with the lighting i i'd like to see
that done even sooner
um so if there was any possibility of
expediting that i would have no
hesitation
in trying to get a budget into this
financial year but i respect that this
financial year is tight
and that it may not be able to be done
until the 22 23 year
although i've been assured by joanne we
have the resources to do it in terms of
people
it's just a matter of getting the ticks
on the board and it may be something we
can look at in the coming year
and the lighting is shocking there's a
lot of areas in our district which are
quite low in lighting and i think it is
a health and safety issue
i think you need to be able to drive to
a place um where there's activity and be
able to see the road quite clearly
especially for those of us with failing
eyesight as we get older
and so that's very very important and i
would have voted my initial thought was
that the path i wasn't sure because i
was scared about the impact
on the walking and cycling budget for
the rest of the district but i've been
reassured that this is an additional sum
and we'll support it
further speakers just write a reply
briefly
can i acknowledge denise uh here today
denise says
has been a long-term advocate for this
including the speed limit so we're
starting to take a few things off
um which and it is absolutely timely
like i attended the
kamato meeting towards the end of last
year and one of the requests
from both denise and auntie joan is that
we actually had a costing
put forward so thanks to jared and
joanne for providing that
because it's been the basis in which we
could actually know what the cost is
going to be of something that's been
requested
for a large number of years so i think
this is a positive way forward look i
hope that this will attract subsidy
i really do and it's our job to put
forward the best case and
certainly in the various forums of
regional transport and other
bodies i will certainly do what i can to
lobby
on behalf of our council and our
community for it to be included
in there council barnett made a good
point around
lighting if if the staff do have the
ability and there is time they
can bring that back by way of staff
submission um through the budget process
so
but i didn't really want to i know
there's a big pro work program going on
with all the other works around water
and i just didn't want to overload the
team
with that so but if you are able to then
that would be welcomed
um i think uh councillor atkinson summed
it up well
when we've got a school in urapa and a
malay
there are very there are no other
community like that in our district
and that's why for me that's an absolute
priority
and ask colleagues all to support this
motion today so with that i'll put the
recommendation or through the motion
all those in favor please say aye
contrary
clear that carried well done denise
all right
great we look forward to seeing you in a
few weeks sorry
at our next engagement thanks denise
you're welcome you're welcome to stay
for the rest of the meeting if you wish
[Laughter]
all right um let's hope let's hope all
our debates aren't perhaps that long
so um but that was a good discussion all
right so our next uh
i'm going to do 4.6 which is town
centres including carpet
okay so that's simon and
joanne jr and simon
that's the report that jim yeah so
uh so we're going to do item 4.6 which
is pound centers it's
on thank you 152.
which is um tav8
good morning everyone i'm pleased to be
able to present this report to you on
behalf of the
town center strategies implementation
working group
i'll uh i'll refer to that group as the
working group from this point forward so
it's not to have to repeat that name
the report's purpose really is to bring
back to the council
the good work of that group uh in trying
to determine
uh funding options and recommendations
for the two town centre plans that have
been adopted that's the wrong eurotown
center plan and the kaiapo chance into
plan which was adopted back in 2018.
we have a number of members of the group
here today and in fact deputy mayor
atkinson councillors ward
and barnett and we had our two community
chairs
also present on that working group along
with a number of staff from the various
units and departments importantly this
report deals with a couple of major
parts of the town centre implementation
one of those being parking and the other
one being about categorization of all of
the projects that sit within those two
two town center plans of which there
were about 70 projects
categorises those and then provides
recommendations on those
you'll remember back in july 2019 last
year
when the rangiora town centre plan was
adopted this group was formed
and following that in august september
and october the group
undertook three quite large workshops to
try and generate a series of
recommendations and and we came up with
those initial recommendations
uh at the end of october as to how to
fund the implementation of all of these
projects
that was then brought to the council's
management team in november
who considered all of those
recommendations and funding options
against the wider long-term plan
planning exercise in context
and also made some recommendations on
how to proceed and that's what resulted
in the categorization that you see
in tables four point in the table under
4.13
which is categories a b and c for the
purpose of this
long-term plan uh the projects in table
in categories a and b have been included
excuse me have been included
into the budget and the projects in
category c have been deferred
beyond this 10-year plan
following that we briefed council on
this very
early in november council also asked us
to go away and bring back this report
which clearly articulated
exactly which units each of these
budgets would be held within so
it was noted that whilst it was really
important to understand what the cost of
implementing these town centre
projects as a whole it's also important
to know where that money sits
in units because there are many projects
and that's what the table in 4.13 tries
to deal to
you'll also note in the report there was
a significant sum of the town centre
funding which is allocated to rangiora
town centre parking
and section 4 details some of the
rationale behind that
and whilst i'm here i'm
happy to open any more comments to my
fellow town centre working group
members that that being the councillors
around the table today who may wish to
add
any other comments but then absolutely
happy to take any questions counsellors
might have about this report
thanks simon uh joan did you wish to
hear something
thank you simon and simon being part of
the working group
i have to say that um the work that's
been done i'm was very very
pleased that you listened um to
our concerns about capital x expenditure
and programs and that what we could
afford what we couldn't afford
particularly with the
um parking issues car parking issues
and what the um resolution that you came
up with
was very economical and delaying the car
parking building till right at the end
which i thought was very very
responsible but at the same time
it was increasing purchasing some land
about increasing the car parking
facilities in in the wranguian
town and i thought you did that really
really well and i congratulate you on
that
and um i'm very pleased to see that
you've covered off
on everything that we wanted to do with
the least cost in the meantime while we
were getting through
these big capex years and leaving it
till the end thank you
thank you councillor look it's just
really around what simon was saying
about the costs that are in here
and then everyone everyone understands
where they where they sit within budgets
we spent
a lot of time trying to because it was
going to be very confusing simon was
going to
give us a whole heap of numbers in a
department that doesn't have a budget
and then they were going to be in the
plan
as well so i just want to reiterate it's
called that you actually understand
where these amounts of money are
within the certain budgets and where
they sit
because if you don't then it really is
worth going into
where and why they sit there as opposed
to a
what would appear to be a separate
budget
but would double up on a budget if that
makes sense so um
if you if you don't quite understand
that 4.1 particularly which i think is
explained well but then
i've been involved in it since the start
so but if you don't
please ask the questions so that it can
be explained where they sit
because they are in other people's
budgets and may look a little strange to
some people
yeah just a question oh sorry paul were
you part of the week
you're part of the weekly party right no
it's just if he gets told sorry i'll put
you
councillor barnett did you wish to i'll
come to you in a minute just just a very
very quick ad because i apologize i
wasn't able to make all the meetings so
and i certainly understand the hard work
that the working party's done
but i just wanted to highlight to
councillors the the number one
project i can see in the category a is
a review of the local economic
development strategy we are going to
face some pretty
tough uh economic times and we need to
make sure we've got our business
community on board and that we are
supporting and
um working on strategies that's going to
actually develop our
economic activity in this district over
the next 10 years and
the 2012 um strategy is well due
to be redone and
especially at this time i actually think
it's the time you need to spend money on
economic development strategy and on
promotion
to the other start any other staff wish
to anything simon
um good morning mr man just briefly
we've taken a program approach here very
consciously
these are two significant town center
plans
they span a wide range of activities
part of the reason for the program
approach is to get
[Music]
within the organisation but also with
the interested community that you just
highlighted
counsellor a sense of
there is a wider commitment to implement
a program of activities
over over the long haul to give
confidence as distinct to
keeping all of these in separate budgets
and considering them
project by project and we tend to
lose ourselves and lose our audience
if we don't have an overall project
approach
but at the same time just to reassure
you we've only counted the costs
once it's good to hear
jim yeah look and just adding to the
comments we've
there's a significant provision for a
car park building and outer years
and at that moment at this moment it's
sitting as a placeholder
there are always conversations occurring
and oneness
sort of underway at the moment with a
with a property owner
about their intentions and how that
could relate to our plan so i
probably want to highlight that
at a point in time if those
opportunities crystallize
that and it looks like it is something
worth considering
it could come back to the council which
may see that provision shift in the
10-year space but at the moment
it's there we want to cons
this is a consultation item in
our consultation document that i'm not
sure if it's uploaded yet
to diligent but is coming which
and and there's really a couple of the
alternate options are
to provide for it as we have to bring it
forward
or to not do it at all and
they are the options that would sit in
our consultation document around
around this proposal thank you thanks
james so
quest questions now council winners
yeah i'm quite um concerned a wee bit
because land
for retail development is
getting very very scarce particularly in
renewal
and we're looking at sight and darwin
street
um for three odd million dollars worth
of
budget um one third of the cost of
an actual building a um a car parking
building because you've estimated the
9 million have we looked at um
at the back of the um civic present
to actually put a car parked building
there
and that would be one-third of it and
still allow land
for the future retail development in
waimakari which
is going to be needed um very very soon
because we're projected to go up to 76
000 odd people
um are we doing the right thing by
using that type of land or should we be
utilizing
something existingly we've got and
spending that
budget towards um progressing and
thinking
of the future better
yeah yes great question and and it was
something that we
looked at quite extensively as to the
various options i think we ended up with
six scenarios of land that could either
be
developed that we already owned or land
that we could acquire and develop or
just land that we could acquire for
upgrade car parking
the land at durham street uh we don't
propose to buy the whole
part of the land it's a large part of
the land but we would
it would still allow for an element of
development but it secures car parking
on what we think is a strategically
important location we did look at the
council
existing car park as an option at the
time of the development of this
this plan and the rangiora town centre
car parking plan or strategy
we were also working alongside the group
that's looking at the
civic precinct as a whole and we looked
at some of the initial concepts and
plans for that
and there was actually within those
plans a small car parking building
floated and it became very evident
quite quickly that i wouldn't supply
enough car parking to the town center
over and above what it needed to supply
for the precinct itself
to make that valuable to make that cost
equation work
and b the way and configuration of the
various buildings and land was not
particularly
great for getting a building on so we
discounted that it's not to say it
couldn't come up as a future option but
in the first instance we discounted that
i just have a question around the
painting of the williams street bridge
um i'm i'm not sure that the budget's
adequate
for that so the first part of the
question secondly
we have asked for other options to be
explored
around the william street bridge
including whether you take the
the pieces in between and you glaze it
or do some other treatment
has that been advanced because that was
asked
for at least good evening well certainly
not long after we started the term so it
would be 12 months ago
so be interested in your answer please
uh yeah great question we you're quite
possibly right that the 50 000 that
we've allocated might not be enough we
in the first instance didn't increase
that sum uh
purely because we were doing some work
on the various options
on the bridge including the balustrade
work that you mentioned
and also the lighting the feature
lighting of the bridge so we've
put that work together as a parcel we've
had a staff member with an rpd
our project delivery unit doing some
work on that and it's now with our
consultant to provide us with some
advice on certain aspects of that
the idea would be to then cost out the
various options both balustrade
paint lighting and the like bring that
back as a report
uh on a as a separate report as a
project to the kyboy
tohiwi community board and then of
course through to council as well with
it
just on the timing of that i do think it
should come to council
importantly but it's important to go to
ktcb but it is our bridge
so uh and it's important that we i think
the council is involved in that
conversation
as well i'm not saying that ktcb will be
important in
that exercise but i would like to see
what those costings are
and before it goes to the board and the
council's had an opportunity to review
those
whether it's by workshop or staff
briefing prior to that
connect because you're looking at doing
this work in 2122
so we probably need to get that sooner
rather than later
we're reasonably confident we can get a
paper to the board or briefing sorry to
the council
in the first instance reasonably in the
next few months hopefully
and the adequacy of budget is that
something to be will you reflect on and
whether the provision needs to change
could we aim to confirm that in light of
the process that you've just referred to
for the deliberations meeting in may so
staff you'll bring that back as the
staff reports that is that going to be a
doable time frame guys
yep i believe we can do that we're the
questions
just on that it was my understanding
there was 131 000 sitting somewhere for
in the maintenance budget for painting
the bridge now
um this is an extra 50 000 this should
because i mean we must have
depreciation i mean it's 12 years ago
that that bridge was painted if not
longer
where's the 130 000
for the cost of that sitting it must be
sitting somewhere
it was 131 000 i remember to remember
the figure distinctly
yeah i don't honestly don't know where
that figure came from um i can have a
look but i
i don't know right now and i don't so
are we saying we've got an
asset in the middle of the town which we
need to maintain
that needs to be painted every so often
that we don't have
any budget for and it's been there since
1961. we have bridge maintenance budget
um yes and we have an annual budget for
that one
but it doesn't sit within the bucket
it's just williams street bridge park so
just
staff have said they're going to bring
that back
by way of staff submission but there
will be a briefing
where will the briefing be likely
we're looking to make decisions about
what to include in the ltp that needs to
be done in may but in advance of that we
need to
have brought back to you verified some
of the
yeah is what's in the budget or not uh
there won't be a separate budget for
this particular bridge but what capacity
might there be
what are the options have you enable you
to have that discussion
do a round of discussion with the board
about options that you would
think would be you might want to be
funding through the ltp
and then confirm that in may okay we'll
leave you to work the timetable yeah
okay okay all right um further questions
so um counselor at consumers have to
move their recommendations
it's contained in the water paper
seconded by council award counseling
just very quickly i hope you'll support
this it's um it's the consultation but
that's
that's really the important but next um
the detail will come out
over time and as needed and i think um
the type of question that we've already
had which was around what council
williams was
suggesting will continue to happen
because it's a bit of a moving feast
until such time as we can
actually put some things on the ground
but certainly the numbers with
redesigning of car parks made a huge
difference obviously enough to
the capacity of parking within the town
so those sorts of things and i mean
no doubt that we'll come back to you as
a full briefing um
in the next trance of things but it's
very important that this is included so
that we can actually do some
consultation and get out there and
find out what people think councilwood
yes i'm happy to support this it's been
a really worthwhile working group
and lots of decisions
to and to look at and the expansion
particularly of both rengara and kharpoi
moving out
is there's lots to do and it's good that
we have a strategy
now that we can we've got somewhere to
go um
so well done and look forward to working
with you again
i can support the recommendation i think
staff have done a very good job working
with the working party to identify the
key
projects as indicated in 4.13 so well
done
team that's a really good program there
of
of activity and they're the ones that i
get asked about all the time
reason i asked about the william street
bridges i've ever asked about
it whenever i go across someone will
stop me and say when are you going to
paint it what are you doing
so it is important that we do get a
decision one way or the other about what
our plan is but
to inform that we do need that work so
that can come to us sooner rather than
later because the cowboy town center is
looking great
that's the last part of it um that's
needing to be
resolved but you know i constantly get
really great remarks from people
that are really impressed with how it's
looking in rengura it's one of the
regular remarks that people coming out
here to have the shopping experience
they like the look and feel of our towns
so
all these projects including parking are
really
important that we do have a a plan there
for addressing
all the matches that are raised in there
so
great job um and look forward to hearing
feedback on
the program any further speakers
do you wish to speak again either at
council award
do you want to use can you tune your
microphone on please
i have been involved in a lot of these
workshops with the um
town centers in the workshop as also the
lighting
and we have got a lighting consultant
and i'm very excited about what he
the plans he has for kai koi and the
bridge i've seen some
um some initial drawings and and design
features and i think kaipu is going to
look stunning
thank you you're the speakers write a
reply counselor
i'll put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye
contrary clear that carrie thanks team
right we now move to the uh
roading activity budget papers
in the folders
jared and joanne do you have any
commentary you'd like to
raise in here
thank you so just in terms of this
current oh so it's page 14
everyone
we're from page 13 on but if we exclude
the
cover page it's page 14.
thank you thank you um i won't go
through every item because i know this
is
quite an uh detailed
uh summary and there's a lot of
information in there i would just note
that it does align
with the briefing that was provided to
council on budgets in december last year
in terms of operations and renewals one
of the main changes that we have
this year is the bridge maintenance and
structures component renewal budget
the bridge maintenance budget has been
reduced
to just the general maintenance
activities
and we have uh this year applied for
funding under structures component
renewal which is some of the more major
work which needs to be done to our
bridges
um we have a catch-up over the first
three years in terms of budget so a
slightly higher budget provision
and that is to address a number of
issues which we have been identified
with
our structures uh
capital improvements so for this
we have really allowed for improvements
around the district with a focus
on our key transport corridors and areas
where we have known
safety issues um skewbridge
i will pull that out as one
that we have included in our bridge to
the rltp the regional land transport
program
however i will note that
due to the low bcr so
we are unlikely to get funding for this
project
um because of the low crash history at
that
site in the low number of this and
serious
injuries this does not result in a high
bca and we are competing against other
projects around the district that have a
much higher crash rate
unfortunately that's the way the
calculation works
it looks at historic data and not
predicted
we are going to be doing some more work
though
on um crash predictions along the
corridor we do have some remaining
budget this year
to try and build a stronger business
case
and then look at we could potentially
look at resubmitting in the next three
years
in the interim we have allowed for some
active warning signage
at the bridge again just to try and
keep people safe in the interim
um we have the
sorry we do have left skewbridge within
the 10 years
of the ltp we have design in year eight
and have allowed for construction in
year nine and ten of the ltp
so if we were able to build a stronger
business case then council could
consider timing
the other one that i will point out is
the new eastern rangiora arterial road
that is um we're suggesting it is
brought forward from
20 35 336
sorry brought forward two 20 35 36 so
that's just outside of the 10 years um
previously it had been sitting out at
39.40
and so we're suggesting that hundred
thousand dollars of budget be bought
into
this 10-year ltp to allow for the
design and consenting to begin
one additional thing i will point out is
an error which
counselor barnett had identified which
was the car park
rates budget um this was showing a
budget
increase to 34 000 and 21 22 but this
was incorrect and it should have been
twenty thousand
which page is that showing it is all
right
it was in the budget in the papers
itself is it
sorry the spreadsheet it's in the
spreadsheet itself
yes it's on page 30 about halfway down
so they're probably they're key points
and look i'm happy to take any questions
that anyone might have
cow's direct concern excuse me
i'm very confused we've gone from 4
million to 7 million to 11 million then
there's a 330 it seems to be
that skew bridge is mentioned in just
about every second line of your budget
um so how much is the project and forget
the subsidy because that only confuses
the conversation so
will it we'll assume there are no
subsidies for anything
what is the budget for skew bridge
because i'm you know there's 330 for
this there's
another item there for different signs
there's the new bridge so there's the
it's very confusing about what we're
spending on skew bridge
so the estimated cost is 11 million
so that's from a cost estimate that
a consultant provided for us
and the 330 000 which is a separate line
item
and the budget is for the active warning
signs
at the bridge so that's the safety
improvement
to help with safety in the interim until
we can
get to the point where we can replace
the bridge
safety scientists and just to be clear
the 11 million in today's dollars when
you get it escalated out there it sits
in our sheets
cumulatively at about 13. so okay and
then now she's here
it's five five and a half and then
seven and a half so about 13 million is
the cumulative difference
okay so that's inflation adjusting right
okay thanks
jim um i'm just interested in the signs
i assume
we're looking at these flashing signs
that say slow down or there's danger or
whatever
my understanding of those that are at um
like pine acres and those
types of things we're talking about
something different because my
understanding is they were 40 grand
and we've got 330 in here for
for that and if indeed it's 330 as
opposed to 40
that we've already got existing why are
we looking at such an extensive is there
is that not just signs is that other
stuff what is that
it would be other measures with those
signs to help reinforce that slower
speed environment
um we haven't done the detailed design
yet and
once we got to the point of working
through and scoping there and designing
it up we'd be able to refine that budget
further
and there is a budget that we've used
some nzta guidance to help us sit
but i agree it may well come and lower
few questions so i've got council um
stuart ward blacky myself by today
okay all right uh councillor stewart
thank you um the budget um
for structures component renewal or
bridges i'm not quite sure but um the
dudley creek creek balustrades
um the whole length of dudley creek
where those um right those
deep green powder coated
railings were put in some 26 years ago i
know because i did a story about it at
the time
they have not been touched since then
and they're really flaking all
off and they look appalling and it was
one of the highlights of that whole 1
million dollar upgrade of dudley creek
is that in your structures component
renewal 375 or where because
where does that come
i believe they would be a drainage asset
and we can have a look as to whether
there's been any allocation of funding
for
um any maintenance on those and you are
quite correct about the
state of them than they are um so
uh we what i'll do is i'll try and get
you an answer before we get to the
drainage commentary today okay and if
you want some nice pictures of them i've
got some because i
did quite extensive features about it um
a second question
can you tell me um on page 29
where there is a series of professional
fees
for capital works remettling
pavement rehabilitation
drainage renewals and chip ceiling
why would we have signs renewal why do
we have
professional fees in these which
i understand well in-house
um or contracted out
like they come under our roading
contract or
our drainage whatever they are set
um there's set functions that
are either done in house so why is there
an extra for professional fees which is
quite substantial when you add them all
up so why is there
remittling twenty thousand dollars in
professional fees
on what is a contract work so why is
there professional friends
the professional fees is for my staff
time
i have a team of nine in total
um for one two three four five of those
guys
are out and about on a daily basis
um looking at rural unsealed roads
looking at reseals and that is the
fees that cover their their staff costs
so they they get shown like this because
as part of the
subsidised um there's a there's a little
thing which is not well unders well
known
is we actually do you agree with that we
have this
for roading activity there's like a
little professional
services team that need to be
established
in the costs allocated against projects
to
gain their acceptance by nzta for
funding so they
so this might have set somewhere else
under
staff costs operations but they they get
tagged
so this is in kennedy or uh
the like out there saying okay um you
need to metal
middle this road yes you've done it if
you know so
that's his time out there looking at
those types of things which gets
allocated
as part of this cost which then makes it
eligible for nzta subsidy
we got that under our asset management
plans that for instance
rode metallic we we've got enough
data in there that x roads need
metalling at various intervals why would
it require
so this is not professional you know
professional fees might be a stretch of
the imagination but it is cost of
staff cost associated with overseeing
the delivery of that program of work
there's probably more correctly
describes what it is thank you um the
other
the other thing oh i did want to you
talked about skewbridge
um of having a low bcr um i just
wondered
what it was and what is the cutoff point
for
nzta
the higher the bca you can get the
better um
and that that because there was a an
accident
on it last year or close to it there's
that
0.54 taking into account
that it's very hard to hear you oh sorry
indeed sorry okay um
for um skewbridge yeah the bcr we've
currently got has been calculated using
all the crash histories that we're aware
of
the issue in terms of the nzta
how the criteria that we have to assess
gives higher rating to serious injuries
and fatalities
and a lot of the crashes that we've had
there although they've been
um you know they've ended up with cars
rolling off the road or losing control
they haven't we don't have the crap the
serious
injuries or fatalities to drive that vcr
armour
thank you and the last one um
the bridge balustrade that is over the
kaikanui is associated with the
um with the cycleway that large
piece of cyclone netting with
my focus on a utility as an artwork i
thought we had really excelled ourselves
there
is that temporary because it better be
deep
you're referring to the new cycle pass
up my north road uh into kaiapoi on the
southern side
it goes across kaikuni it it's had the
painted um um wooden
stuff one's gone now and now we have
a goal of soccer goal like structure of
cyclone knitting and seriously
counsellors
sorry the question is that permanent
is that the permanent balustrade for
this entrance way to south kaiapoi
i will have to follow up with with my
team and find out
okay um so no few questions so council
award
yes no no no no
for the quiz for council stuart i was
sorry just checking there was no it's a
council award
thank you um you wish to ask a question
would it be a good idea with this sku
bridge
application to include a walking cycling
as part of it do you think that might
get it across the line
a little bit better that's number one
number two is that south brook
improvements you've in there there's
five million in the next ten years
towards that one million for light and
there's two lots of two million
i would argue that would it be possible
to put that four million question please
yes
would it be possible to put that four
million towards the eastern ranger
arterial road which is this
um could be brought forward which i
think is really really important
okay so i think you've asked your
question now yes um but i just want to
say that that would be
ndta funding joan it's really important
that we
continue we keep it to questions for in
fairness to everyone
all right thank you okay you've asked
your question thank you
so firstly in terms of sku bridge
walking and cycling
i think the reality is what is
its safety that's possible probably
going to be the thing that gets
that across the line um we are having
those discussions with our consultant
and they have gone to get some
more technical input into an expertise
into
what the best way is to try and actually
build this business case together across
the line so that is work that we're
doing at the moment
um the walking and cycling i think the
key thing to that is we need to have our
strategy our network plan finished and
and
that will provide the evidence that yes
this is a route that we want to develop
um
so it definitely adds another tick to
the box
but on its own probably not enough
um in terms of the south brook
so what we have um
in the budgets is two million
for the intersection of coronation
street for signalizing their interests
all right let me just quickly find the
correct page
it's in um
[Applause]
in the summary it's it's on page 15.
it's got 1.8 million or southbrook
yeah so 1.8 that's correct
and then southbrook futures of 2 million
yeah
so we have 2 million within the 10 years
and then we had a further 2 million
outside of the 10
years and that was really acknowledging
that there was some work needed to be
done
to look at what the options were for
south brook road and potentially
improving
the capacity and that if we were to look
to do that work we would need to
potentially do things like
widen the bridge at pick and save at the
brook um because that's one of the
constraints at the moment
to putting more lanes and through there
so that was the thinking behind that
um the estimated cost for
the eastern arterial road is around 2.6
kilometers long
and from memory it had three bridges
over it so working up an estimate from
what it cost us to build the new
arterial road
um i'm estimating that that's going to
be around 21 million
of which it should comply with nzta
funding
we did not get any nzta funding at all
on the new arterial road that was fully
funded by
council and i think it's very unlikely
that we would get funding for a new road
when it's primarily driven by growth
okay any other questions here
councilwood
so come to councillor becky thank you um
one minute bridge maintenance journey
and we've got three lots coming up in 23
28 i ca on
page 28 the bridge maintenance figures
there
um have you allowed for that because
the amounts you've got written there in
those years going going into the ltp
don't look enough to get anyone out of
bed to fix a major bridge
because are we going to um we're not
going to be hit with a
well there were only we only paid 25
percent of it sure
but are those is that bridge or is it
somewhere else and i've missed it or is
that bridge maintenance figure there
enough to cover that um womack bridge
apologies the funding for that is
included on page 31
we've put them in as specific line items
because
christchurch city are applying
for the funding and from nzta for that
work
so all that will be is we will just pay
nzta our portion um
excluding any nzta funding so
that's why the flight is sorry
thank you any further questions thereal
joan in um how would you tune your mic
to
thank you um just a question for me it
relates
follows on from councillor um ward's
questions around southbrook
uh and so the the tallest street
coronation street improvements it's this
coming year
is that correct um what we have done
is to ensure there's sufficient time to
deliver that project yes
we have the design and year one of the
nlt of the long-term plan sorry 2122
and construction and 22-23
okay and the south brook import
improvements more broadly
are in the 2627
for a study of improvements with 26
000 vehicle movements do you think that
that timing is appropriate
uh given that there are already outlined
the
some of the projects that could be
potentially explored do you think that
should be brought forward
to be considered earlier
um that's a really good question um if
we were to bring funding forward i think
it would just be the investigation um
that
could potentially be done i did have a
discussion with
um one of the traffic signal staff
from sea talk the other day about how
some quick wins could be made through
the area
and that could form part of that um
yeah so it's just trying to balance that
it could be some
i guess initial work done by my team
within our current
road management budgets could you
so bearing that in mind do you think
that
would you like an element of budget
sooner to undertake that work than 26
27 so to undertake that study i'm
probably
comfortable with optimizing looking at
whether we can optimize that
as an action for my team within current
budgets
and then if we felt at the next annual
plan that needed to come forward then we
could come back to you at that time
i wonder if you could reflect on a
commentary in what goes out because i'm
sure granger ashley community board will
submit on this
and i know our community have a great
deal of interest so
if we're undertaking that work
internally it would be very helpful to
perhaps
consider some wording that captures that
is it okay thank you
council barna
thank you joanne for answering all my
questions ahead of time as well
just wanted to tease out a couple of
them a little bit further
the footpath renewals going down over
the 10-year period
has nzta had any conversations with you
about the aging population
and the need for better quality
footpaths as our population
gets older
so nzta will only
fund my understanding is from the poor
and very poor
for path renewals and that is if we've
got
a footpath that's an average condition
we need to manage that through
maintenance
so ensuring things like tripping hazards
uh
dealt with cracks in the footpath
if it's a concrete path a ground out are
done through the maintenance budget as
opposed to the renewal
so the renewal is when we have big long
stretches
and we have our condition rating and
nzta
aware so that gets uploaded into ram in
terms of our asset conditions
and then nzta are aware of the condition
of our footpaths
around the district so it's different in
managing
we don't want to be over investing and
replacing footpaths that are in a
in an average condition there's no need
for us to be doing that
um and nzta wouldn't they wouldn't be
happy to fund
that so that's definitely a balance um
i think over the last year we've had a
really big
push on our top paths and we've spent
our footpath maintenance budget
um to the maximum each year that we are
starting to see
in the condition rating that we're
pulling that back issue we've got
less um poor and very poor footpaths
to replace so i think if we keep on top
of that maintenance side of things
then um actually reducing our renewal
program as a as an appropriate mode
thank you and the second question i had
was on the construction of park and ride
ravenswood
with the budget allocation in 2930
well considering that people drive to a
park and ride and then get on a bus
um is there a danger that will
predominantly be used by hironui
residents
and is there possible that we could have
a conversation about the
locations of that going forward to make
sure that there's an equity in the
funding of that
yeah that's a really interesting one
and i think
you know i guess the thought pattern
behind
the park and ride and ravenswood is
we've got a significantly growing
commercial
area there's a lot of residential
properties
there's a path from pegasus
across the roundabout to ravenswood
there's
the shared user pass through
ravenswood's a really good connection
into ravenswood um we
are finding like at the new parking lies
that things like the bicycle cages are
actually getting used really well
um so we yes we definitely do get people
driving but we are getting people biking
or walking to them as well so it's
trying to capture
a number of different
i guess people and users from the
different areas
and we would be anticipating that we
would get
local interest in local people using the
facilities
in terms of numbers per new people
i'm not sure it's not something that
we've spoken to them about
or i guess done any research on as to
whether people
say from amberly would want to use them
it's
probably just worth adding um look we've
got park and road facilities in rangiora
and kaiapoi and and actually to some
extent
serving the lifestyle areas of
mandeville through the
southern kaiapoi car park area um if you
add up the population of wood-end
pegasus and two here it starts to become
a third major centre for the district
and so it's really trying to provide
provision for that
area um for the same kind of level of
service that we're providing to the
other big towns
um and look you will get people from
outside the district who use
those as christchurch will get that um
our residents using some of their
facilities
as well and i suppose um
[Music]
yeah look at that that's potentially a
byproduct of the success of it if it
does
that it does get to be so successful but
just just to challenge those hesitations
um wouldn't people who live in pegasus
or would end
area just simply catch the bus to a
quiet boy i mean if they are walking
they would not walk to a park and road
facilities and not group
i guess it depends where they're going
where their destination is
and if you've got a direct service um
in the future uh there could be an
opportunity for the direct service that
currently goes from kaiapoi to go
would end kaiapoi and then straight into
town
um yeah i guess there are lots of
options
and there's always the argument that
every car that you can actually get off
the road helps with congestion
so yeah hopefully that means someone
wins
uh councillor williams
yeah um parking right again we had the
original budget dream
as a holder sort of thing a four million
dollars
how much that's been spent so far how
much change we got left
um good question from memory it was
around
two million i think and there was a
couple of million that hasn't been spent
yet so that's been pushed out and
in the plan yeah so
that um ravens would would that be um
part of that two million being pushed
out as well
good question um
you've actually got 1.6 on the um other
button it goes to 1.863
so i think the two million was kept in
the uh in kaipoi
and rangiora acknowledging that
um in the future if demand continues to
increase
there's likely to be need to increase
park and ride services
um so the likes of the kiwis site
might need to be extended in the future
or the new world site if we found that
one of those was
particularly popular which we're seeing
obviously now
so what i'm getting at the yeah there's
no extra budget for cop or your renewal
that's
so that yeah so the the two no so the
two million dollars
that split over kai poi and rangiora in
years four and five
and the additional budget is the
ravenswood parking ride line
which wasn't currently allowed for but
that's out in year 9.
thank you jill thank you joanne just a
query
um the old historic
waimakariri gorge bridge there's nothing
in here do we not
pay for anything for upgrading that
bridge
uh yep that's a really good question i
have had a discussion
with selwyn district council on
maintenance needs for the bridge
you'll remember about eight years ago
the timber deck was replaced
and the structure itself is sound
what we do have and what we do see is
the chip seal because the bridge deck
moves as the cars drive over it the chip
seal over time cracks and falls off
and it's looking a bit shabby at the
moment yeah so it's due for a reseal
um so i wanna just working with the
contractors
who are here consult are contracting
um and they are looking to resell that
probably within the next one to two
years now we would
manage that through our bridge
maintenance budget so
yeah that's important okay
uh councillor atkinson followed by
council meetings
casamayors
just on page 32 on the
community road safety and sustainability
projects
um i note that there first of all i just
wonder what the sustainability projects
portion of that budget was there was 18
000 allocated in the 2021
annual plan and then it seems to have
disappeared
what was it in the first place and has
it been reallocated elsewhere or
abandoned
sorry i am too
and that makes it let's see
um
29 on page 29 of that budget
these are just too small
[Music]
that's about that third category down
from the top of the page
yep
hmm i actually have to go away and
follow that up i'm not sure why
um was that planting or whatever what
was that
really where did it go
the remainder of that budget the line
above the road safety projects
is basically uh road safety operations
okay any further questions
just at this point i'm happy to allow
any general comments
colleagues wish to make i just like to
say um thanks joanne
to you and your team it's a really big
piece of work putting together the
writing budget
and for the range of questions you've
had given the level of detail
um it's it's probably their most visible
because it's the one we get the most
feedback about we're all
we've said many times all amateur rating
engineers we have many in our district i
get feedback quite regularly
i've also appreciated the um that you've
kept
council williams and myself as
respective portfolio holders in this
area
um well briefed and certainly taken us
through
where you were planning to head in terms
of managing
i guess our 10-year program and as it
was said through
out the discussion points you know if we
can attract
funding or support for means eta
then we can bring these projects board
at any time
which is important and i really welcome
our new chief executive in coming on
board with his expertise nzte
and i had a conversation the other day
around possible strategies that
can be looked at but the fresh shed of
eyes given his
expertise he may have some ideas about
how we may be able to get some of these
up
sooner including skew bridge obviously
wooden bypass is one that we raise all
the time in fact i was
on a a zoom call yesterday with a um
regional transport and they reminded me
that i sound like a bit of a broken
record
because they are projects if we don't
keep mentioning them they
fall out of people's currency and south
rock
particularly as important as the other
projects but south
particularly is a lot of visibility in
that area
and i think it's really important that
we keep the investigations up there
around the things that they make some
improvements here and
counts awards right around um eastern
europe
and in that so let's let's hope we can
get that project over the line in time
but i think it's
i think it's worth and john and the team
are doing
the designation work now as well but
it's
just talking to alistair the other day
it's actually when we're doing our
commentary out it's about the bau
business as usual the stuff that we
actually are doing
we've we know we're doing but sometimes
we're just not very good at getting that
comms out to remind people that these
projects are
in train and it's about continually
keeping those at the forefront i know in
the ltp we've got certain requirements
but
we actually are doing a lot of good work
and across the board and it's just
reminding people
of that at every opportunity we get
any other comments generally counts the
ward followed by
council stuart and barna i just want to
reiterate
i'm being part of the long-term plan
meetings with you dan
and i looked at my notes in september of
the wishes and the things we had to do
what we actually achieved by the end of
december was phenomenal
so thank you so much with all the shovel
really projects and all the other things
and the long-term plan and everything i
think
where we've progressed even since
september is
really really fantastic well done
council oh sorry council stewart
followed back in savannah i wanted to
ask a question about the use of the
um cycle loan across the bridge
um i've seen so many people on it and
coming
actually unfortunately into kaiapoi and
hitting
you know where the cycleway had stopped
over the holiday period and
you know there's a whole group
but what has been the use um it looked
like it was getting decent use because
i've seen cyclists all the time
do we have any snacks we don't have any
stats just yet because the counters i
believe are still going in
on the cycle way but yeah as soon as we
get that information
happy to share i i drive out the cnc
i counted 15 people and one of our staff
members i met who was coming in the
door today had cycled from parkland so
definitely seeing an
increase um yeah it's really really
exciting to see
we've got to get the bus patronage too
actually
yeah yeah we'll get some data that we
can share with council will meet
thank you council
yes thank you i'm very very impressed
with the work that joanne and jared have
done in the
roading space i think you've worked
really really hard to raise some of
those standards particularly on the
footpaths which were
a concern in some areas um
nzta or should we say wakahi
um has had to respond to changing
government priorities and
and i think that's part of their problem
is they've had to
juggle from one to the other and i think
we may well have got different responses
if there'd been different
um priorities up north but i do wonder
how much they've spent on branding every
time they've changed their name and that
could have gone into eroding
um that's just tongue-in-cheek away but
um the only thing i would like to say is
i just want when we when we look at a
strategic routing budget
look at our priorities first whether or
not that meets in zta criteria
look at our priorities first do it from
that lens and then we've got to look
what we can get
because i do think other councils some
of the councils have been more
successful at that somehow
they've been a bit more aggressive
they've been a bit more forward i know
we want to build a great relationship
but we have to turn around and say well
the buck stops here for our people
we want our arterial roads to be
drivable we want to have the right level
of service in our district
so i i guess what i'm saying is is don't
be afraid to challenge
the fact that we have got limitations
but at the same time
i understand the the restrictions that
you work with so i really appreciate the
work that you do
thank you yes i'd just like to come back
and mention about the
the cycling between rangiora
and i mean one waimakariri in
christchurch i actually was in
christchurch recently
and i actually met one of the staff
members that took his children
for a ride through there is that correct
jared
correct
any other speakers council atkinson
pretty quickly on the park and ride that
that councillor barnett
um mentioned i just
while i actually have great sympathy
with that people using cross
boundaries if you like but we need to be
very careful i remember the
cranford street conversation if we did
not supply then
we had the cross boundary arguments i
know
that there are people coming from
kaianga and using the kaiapoi one
however they are the very people that
are shopping in the supermarkets your
car boy so
there are added benefits and minuses so
while i don't
uh don't oppose a bit of an
investigation see how many people are
doing that with some statistics so i'm
pretty scared scared of a cross-boundary
charge because it works sort of both
ways and i know
christchurch would dearly love to have
that argument
all right i don't think there's any
other speakers so look thank you jared
and joanne that's the writing budget
complete um so we'll now break for lunch
and it's in the green room everyone
could be back here at 1
15. that would be really good thank you